hi leah how are you pleasure to meet you
like i when i think of you like like the
word that comes to my mind
is just lovely oh a
lovely soul oh my gosh thank you
that means so much to me first of all
really quickly
i know that you're a nail enthusiast and
i was gonna wait to ask you this
question but i can't
what is going on how do any of us
achieve this
wow your nails are so extraordinary
they're really inappropriate for my age
but these are like lips
with a grill and i i don't like i don't
know why i just love
nails i love hair and makeup i love the
whole
thing and my daughter thinks i'm
ridiculous she's probably right
but i love them i enjoy them i does your
daughter
she's 16 is that correct yes she finds
nothing about me interesting
um i i i'm sure that's not true or it's
just an
act you know a phase act um does she
like anything girly is she like while
she's
you know being like yeah your nails does
she have little things she gets into
she's look she's a big fan of makeup she
buys tons of makeup she hoards the
makeup
she doesn't necessarily wear a lot of
makeup but
the thing that is really true to who my
daughter
is like i i have love notes from my
daughter that i frame around the house
she
actually is a like a lovely human being
she sends me things that i should be
posting on social media
about systemic racism social inju
like constantly saying mom you need to
be doing this you know i need
less plastics in this house you know
here's another water we need to have
like she's very conscious
and and that's why she gets away with
being 16
to her mom i mean i have
eight and almost seven and when i was
reading about you saying like you know
the homework or
like you know i mean my daughters
recently unfortunately were not feeling
well and they were sick
and uh they couldn't do homeschool and i
was
very relieved because i hate that
homeschool is so hard i was like oh
they're sick we can't be at the home
school today it's so hard
yeah like literally people doing this
with their
caretakers with mom's dad they deserve
an award i mean i tried to do homework
with her one
time i couldn't even understand the
question i don't even understand what
they're asking you to do
what do they want you to do google it i
don't know
it's like i couldn't even help in any
way shape or form
the patience because you know our kids
will do things for other people like
how many times you know your kids have
had a sleepover and you get a text from
the mom or dad or kid saying oh your
daughter's like she made your um like
she made the bet what
i try to put the fear uh
of just everything wholly out in the
universe into my children when they go
over to said friend's house i'm like
we're talking your their mom and i are
talking afterwards
and i'll know everything that you do
right
right exactly exactly yes well
she's she's lovely at other people's
house lovely i love that she's so woke
too like with the plastic and my
daughter was canvassing
you know throughout the building and i i
sometimes wish that we could be raising
kids like with
playing till the street lights go on and
no social media but that's just not the
world we live in and
and i do think a trade-off is this
wokeness this awareness it's incredible
i wasn't thinking about these things
when i was her age i was thinking about
jordash and sergio valente
you know that that's what i was thinking
about right and so to have
right same same no
because i was
maybe a little sassoon yeah exactly
candy candy
they are now aware of the world around
them
and they are uh it to me
it makes me so proud to know that she's
somebody who cares about what's
happening in the world
that isn't just about her world that
she can affect change well
i think in this day and age they'll
teach
us things as we teach them
things and uh i'm just
i was really excited to talk to you
about your daughter because i'm raising
two girls
and um it's such a privilege and it's so
wild out there in this current world
and um there are things to navigate but
things to
sort of embrace as well and how that we
do that dance is such an art
i'm so excited to talk to you
about people puzzler i'm freaking out
i'm the biggest crossword puzzle person
and people magazine is one of the best
crosswords ever so
this show thank you
yes i love i mean it's so great when
they called me they said do you want to
do a game
show i was like no because i'm not
smarter than a fifth grader so no
and they were like no no do you want a
coaster game show and i was like ah
do i want to host a game show okay uh
well what you know what is it because
if it's like you know jeopardy type
stuff you know that's just stuff
and is it celebrity driven because i
really didn't want to do like you know
celebrities you know and they said no
it's it's you know the people magazine
crossword
and game show network teamed up to do
this people you know it's pop culture
it's fun facts i was like oh my god i
love that
and it's normal people yes yes so
um it came at a time you know we're all
still you know
on lockdown and i i was like i wanted to
get out and i love people like i love
talking to people like if you invite me
to
you know your cousin's house
like that it's a it's a backyard
barbecue like i'm so i'd rather do that
any day
than go to a red carpet event like any
day right
and so getting out of the house and and
being with
contestants every day like that i love
the moments before
you know they said action where i was
like hey mary tell me about oh you know
and it was just
fun and easy and every time they lost
you i was like i'm so sorry
you know i wanted to give them something
i felt bad and
every single person was like i'm just
happy to be here leo like i had the best
time today and it just reminded me the
joy
of people connecting it's a fun show i'm
not good at it
but i really love that people are